hello chess fans i'm sam copeland
national master on the content team here
at chess.com and i'm here today with
another
amazing computer chess game this game
was played in a bullet test tournament
between komodo and the chess engine
scorpio
i'm going to go ahead and claim at the
outset of this video
that this is the best chess miniature
that i have seen
this century in fact the game doesn't
really feel like it's from this century
much less the 1900s it feels like it's
from the 1800s the era of paul morphy
and adolf anderson white sacrifices
material at
every turn and finishes with a beautiful
beautiful checkmate the game opens up
with e4
e5 and something original here on move 2
bishop c4 the bishop's opening
now the computer chess championship
games are played with an
opening book used to make the games more
interesting so the engines don't always
play the most reliable openings
like the berlin they do discover new
territory
so i'm not exactly sure when the engines
were out of book but it's usually the
first two or three moves
so this definitely feels like one of
those moves now black plays bishop c5
and if they're not following book knight
f6 would probably have been better than
bishop c5
the problem with bishop c5 is that black
is copying white but why does it move
ahead
and so white should be better equipped
to achieve c3
and d4 and attack and gain time
by harassing that bishop so after bishop
c5 we now see knight to f3 attacking the
pawn here on e5
and now we see pawn to d6 white goes for
the idea i just mentioned pawn to c3 to
step forward with pawn to d4
and to attack that bishop and build a
great center with a gain of time
the next move is very unique to me queen
to e7
i generally don't like having a queen on
e7 but of course when the bishop is no
longer on f8
it's much more reasonable however this
move still seems to work out very very
badly for black
but the only way to take full advantage
of this slight
error is really to sacrifice material
which komodo shows
very very quickly that it is willing to
do so d4 is now very very natural
and i wonder if one of the reasons for
queen e7 is maybe a miscalculation from
the engine
it seems like queen e7 is kind of
designed to allow pawn takes d4 pawn
takes d4
queen takes e4 check but this is a
mistake
queen e7 has not stopped to break d4
because now after king f1
black has problems the bishop is under
attack
and if the bishop falls back there's the
nice move bishop takes
f7 white is gaining a huge advantage
white did have to move the king
but now black also has to move the king
and white's gaining more tempos with
moves like knight c3
very very soon if the king captures the
bishop
the problem is knight g5 check with a
royal fork
winning the game so after pawn to d4
what we actually see is the move bishop
back to b6
right away and now knight g5 a common
problem beginning players know well the
difficulties that you can have
when trying to defend this f7 pawn now
black could play bishop e6 and accept a
weakened pawn structure but white is
definitely better there
so black tries knight to h6 instead
after knight to h6 white goes ahead and
castles and we get knight to c6
putting pressure on the pawn on d4 it is
at this point in the game
that i really think komodo starts to
show its stuff
we get the move pawn to a4 going for the
move pawn to a5 which will disrupt the
coordination
of the minor pieces now of course black
can capture on d4 which is what scorpio
goes ahead and does
and we do get a 5. tactically the only
option here is to capture with the
bishop if you capture with the knight
white has the nice tactic
rook takes a5 bishop takes a5 and queen
a4
check and a fork white is gaining
material and has a huge advantage in
this position
notice that black also can't pull the
bishop to c5 because the move pawn b4
would trap the bishop on c5 so
after a5 we do get bishop takes a5 and
white takes back on d4
and gains a beautiful center in this
position though
black pulls back to b6 and there's a big
question
what are you doing about the pawn on d4
a natural developing move like bishop e3
actually shows some of the problems
there is the move bishop takes d4 and
black is undermining the defense of this
knight
in fact in this position scorpio is
doing really
really well so instead after bishop to
b6 we see
another sacrifice knight c3 in this game
in general komodo shows a total disdain
for its pawns
it's always willing to give up pawns if
it can get piece activity
so after knight to c3 we see bishop
takes d4
knight to d5 this is
a beautiful beautiful night it's
definitely going to have
a huge role to play in this game the
queen falls back to d8
and i love the next move as well rook to
a3
an early rook left the rook is coming
over to the king side and it's going to
be
very very potent now i think that the
next move
is probably a mistake from scorpio i
think it is losing
possibly better is the move bishop to g4
disrupting white's coordination and
encouraging the queen to move
now white has a ton of activity and
probably an advantage after the move
queen d2
but is white winning as in the game i
don't think so yet
deep analysis by chess engines does not
indicate a clear win
and at least after the move played in
the game which is
castling i can no longer find a defense
so after rook to a3 we do get castles
and now rook to g3 creating a
ton of latent threats now one thing to
appreciate in this position
is just how darn difficult it is to move
anything for black
the pieces don't look to be so badly
placed but they don't really have
targets or anything productive to do
in the position as a human the natural
thing to do seems to be to move this
bishop out
we want to develop it but the
developments lose tactically
for example after bishop e6 white can
take on e6 and after pawn takes e6 there
is bishop takes
h6 this is a huge idea in the position
the idea to move the knight on g5
and then take the knight on h6 now after
capturing on h6 you may well notice that
there is a knight loose on d5 but after
pawn takes bishop takes d5 check
white is winning for example after king
h8
we cannot take on g7 right away and give
mate because the square is defended but
we can play
queen takes d4 making the first
of many queen sacrifices in this game
after queen takes d4 if the knight
captures it as mate
but ultimately it is made in two after
anything
that black tries so after bishop takes
d5 check more sensible is
rook to f7 here but there are many wins
one win is bishop takes
king takes and then queen to b3 check
king back
and then rook f3 check after bishop f6
queen e6
is really really pretty in this position
the king can't move at all
really there's no productive move and
the idea of rook
takes f6 basically wins against anything
that black tries
another bishop development to mention is
the idea of bishop d7
when white can't move the knight by
capturing anything but you don't
necessarily need to capture when you
move the knight to make big threats
in this position knight to f3 threatens
knight takes d4
and bishop takes h6 winning the game
so what we actually get is the move king
to h8
a very sad move to have to play when
you're under attack
you're desperate to get your pieces into
the game so that they can contribute
and when you have to play moves like
king h8 instead you feel like you're
really a sitting duck and your opponent
is just continuing to take
cheap shots at your chin so after the
move king h8 we get queen h5 the queen
is
beautiful over on the h5 square the
bishop now does develop
2e6 and in this position
white has a crushing and beautiful move
knight takes h7 boom
a strong and decisive knight sacrifice
now in this position because of the many
threats including bishop takes h6
there is really no alternative to
accepting the knight's sacrifice king
takes h7
now in this position the idea is either
to play bishop d3
or e5 and both moves are part of a
decisive attack
obviously the bishop is participating in
the attack but
also the e5 brake will close off this
bishop's ability to defend g7
that's important because if the bishop
is not defending g7 we can often
sacrifice our rook
and force mate or the win of material so
it's hard to decide between the moves e5
and bishop d3
but deeper calculation that you can
check in the notes shows that komodo's
bishop d3
is the better move after bishop d3 in
this position one idea
might be knight to e5 to stop the e5
break
and to attack this bishop down here but
in this position we've blocked the
bishop on d4
so it's time to sacrifice the rook rook
takes g7
king takes and queen takes h6 now in
this position after king g8
knight to f6 check there's no way to get
out of check other than giving up the
queen
and after queen takes f6 you can't
capture on d3
because your own bishop hangs so white
is up too much material
and white wins the game fairly easily in
the game we see a better defensive try
it is the move
rook to h8 now in this position i think
most humans would want to go for the
move e5 check
but this move is a big mistake there is
king g8
bishop takes h6 and then bishop takes e5
in this position you did win the knight
on h6 but you're already down at night
so you're still down material
and you're in trouble in h6 you're in
trouble on d5 and you are in trouble on
g3
in fact there is a draw here but i'm not
going to tell you what it is
because the idea is going to come up
again in the game but with a little
twist that makes it a winning idea
so what's actually played after rook to
h8 is the move
bishop to g5 awkwardly attacking the
black queen
so that queen moves over to c8 now one
alternative idea instead of queen c8 is
the move g6
this is a clever idea because if you
capture the knight then after king g8
your own queen is trapped and although
you can trade queens by capturing
black's queen
it's not so easy to win the game but
after g6 we can play e5
pinning this pawn so it can't capture
and now black has too many problems on
h6
and on d8 white's attack should be
decisive here
so after bishop g5 we did get that move
queen c8
and now e5 check king g8 bishop takes h6
bishop takes e5 and this is very
very similar to the position we just
looked at where i said that white could
not win the game
however there's a difference black's
queen has had to move
and so now white has a forced winning
continuation
if you want to play like komodo pause
your video and find the
only decisive way the winning move here
is
queen takes e5 boom
a tremendous and immediately decisive
move
again this feels straight out of the
1800s straight out of paul morphy's and
adolf anderson's handbook
now there's no alternative to accepting
the queen sacrifice because
white still has a huge attack in this
position
so pawn takes e5 rook takes g7
check and king over to f8 but still
in this position what does white have as
a follow-up
it's another sacrifice rook to g8
and double check because it's double
check
check from both the bishop and the rook
here it's not possible to capture the
rook with the rook
instead only the king can capture and in
this position
there is knight to f6 and check
mate it's a good thing the queen is no
longer on the d8 square
this is a beautiful checkmate i hope
you've enjoyed this whole game but
certainly the finish
with queen takes e5 punch number one and
then
rook takes g7 and rook to g8 punch
number two
and finally knight to f6 the knockout
blow
is just a dazzling dazzling idea
and i hope you enjoyed it as much as i
do i hope you also found it to be the
best chess miniature
that has existed in this century if you
want to check out more really beautiful
often more sophisticated computer chess
games then definitely click on the
playlist
that is popping up on your screen